greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happened now is brought to you
by me undies my favorite underwear in
the whole wide world me and these are
the most comfortable and fun on these
you and your significant other will ever
ever ever own that may feel the softest
materials on earth we're talking three
times softer than cotton sort now you
want to look good with your little
cheeky on Valentine's Day right then
check out the me on these matching pairs
a unique fun gift for you and your
Valentine they're the perfect balance a
comfortable fit and exciting prints
don't spend another Valentine's Day
given the same old gift chocolate
flowers blah blah blah you show up with
some me on these you drop your pants and
you show her your matching and that's
real love gonna be on these calm right
now and find the best match for your
match for starters me undies has an
exclusive day offer for you guys if you
purchased me on these matching pairs you
get 20% off and free shipping who's
better than uncle Joey 20% off and free
shipping to make you a little date
happier than all he'll go to me on these
calm right now and check it out number
two listen you're a couple of weeks away
from Valentine's Day the last two
Valentine's Day eight chocolate by
yourself in it it's not your breath
that's not the look on your face because
love is love it's not the owner of your
armpits maybe your [ __ ] just stinks
so bad that it's creeping out of your
sweatpants oh you ever have an air smell
that bad your missus in there reading
the paper on the train he gets money
your own ass I've been there I know you
have to eat that hummus [ __ ] that's is
why you need a portable bidet and how
old push is there to serve that [ __ ]
[ __ ] of all its cleansing purposes
you asked me Joey what is up a portable
bidet like I just said you hook it up to
your bathroom you don't need a plumber
it takes 10 minutes unless you're a
[ __ ] half a Momo
and you know what your future is filled
with an [ __ ] that's fresh and clean
and all hours of the day even if you go
to the gym and you sweat up a little bit
you know time to jump in the shower you
sit on that midday you take that [ __ ] of
debt and then you let that water hit you
[ __ ] tip top Magoo you dip the
nutsack and then I give her another
once-over so the balance of the sweat
doesn't hit your nutsack you towel it
dry with me on these towel not on me on
these town a hello to chi-town and
you're ready to rock and roll but
therefore all this happened for this
fantasy to unfold you gotta go - hello -
she's calm right now they've got bad
days that come all different colors and
they've started $69 with a 60-day
money-back guarantee who's better than
you Lee and I have had one for years and
it's with stainless thinks of our
[ __ ] you're a decent person he'll
would stain the stinks of your [ __ ]
so got a Hello - she calm right now I'm
pressing Church and get 10% off your
birthday
kick that [ __ ] muley it's a
beautiful [ __ ] day to be alive uncle
Joey here with his main man sinned queer
in sin kidding kidding
let's do close enough close enough and
my main man the Christ killer still
recovered from Austin Texas who the
quesos been coming out of his [ __ ] by
the youngsters but that's what he gets I
told don't go to choose you did not say
that don't go to Chuy's without
alka-seltzer you can tell me I should
get some yogurt on the way back and I do
that because their microbiota stomach
intestines are ready like that why did
they I need a [ __ ] bicycle
I can eat a bicycle nut now how do you
know that already because I've eaten a
half a bicycle a long time no because
you got to take care your stomach a
little kombucha for yoga from time to
time I had no idea
sure without the fruit don't be a half a
[ __ ] it's going on my bed talk to me baby
boy rocking and rolling man you can walk
in ministry yeah man the Kings yeah 1992
destroyed load up a losing the whole
[ __ ] absolutely
and they've been together since like the
80s in early 80s like 81 82 and you're a
kid listen to this stuff BIA one day I
was like I mean I was in high school man
when I first heard ministry and and you
know it was always like [ __ ] I wish I
could be in a band like this I wish I
could be in a band like this and it's
[ __ ] crazy how life happens man and
how it turns out now what was the first
time you joined the band how old I was
let's see it was 2000 late 2005 so I was
like 36 that's the first time you joined
a band that V band Abed oh no no a band
a band involved with Abed 18 before that
I mean you know little garage bands but
like the first band that like I actually
played out like the whiskey and [ __ ]
like that I was 18
yeah what was the name of that bad
rampage
no [ __ ] this is 1987-88 something like
that in the [ __ ] dude like sex trip
it's when you know it was like did there
were more people on the Sunset Strip
outside on the street then in the club's
like it was just jam-packed and you
would see just all the cats from every
band just out there flying passing out
flyers because that's how you did it
back then is you know there's no
internet it was just like word-of-mouth
and it was you're out there flyering
just handing Flyers out you know every
Friday Saturday night the Sunset Strip
from like from the whiskey to gazzarri's
which was what you know what the Key
Club turned into it was just jam-packed
every weekend yeah
and what was it like during the week
with it bands it was still bands playing
yeah but like the weekend was when it
was just it was [ __ ] mayhem out there
man you know I've been here for 20 years
and I bump into people tonight at a time
you know I don't know that names just
interesting people in a bill they have
and you've asked them like when I lived
on Sunset mm-hmm there was a chick that
lived on the second floor
this is 98 and she had been there
already for 20 years mm-hmm so I asked
her I know how was it this cuz we got
there there was hookers still on Sunset
yeah by a curse on seven
there were still hookers then hamburger
stand that they made famous and move
times what the all-american learning in
burger oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
forget I used to bring us his hookers
they're right there yeah hamburger
gentle sunset it's not even there no
more waiting
I don't even know where it used to be
with what would he do with the method
hooker was a joy ride on Sunset
Boulevard in the [ __ ] right in the
open doing the afternoon three black
chicks an asian chick and a chubby white
chick with blonde they're right outside
there and he'd be sitting there eating
[ __ ] burgers all day said them
[ __ ] out right from there you know
many times I walked past to hell I mean
to last the first two years I was here
it was open mm-hmm no it was there but
it wasn't open that's what I meant to
say the building was still there but
yeah yeah yeah but she was just telling
me like we lived on that schraeder
Gardner mm-hmm between no compadre yeah
Russell a good man said it now and she
was outside pointing at places one day
you know we were telling the story here
that that garage behind that place
Ralphie may live there and in that
hallway Matthew McConaughey rented
garages even after he was huge Wow just
to work on his cars and Ralphie would
torch him
she's like that guy's a punk up the
corner if you go up the corner on
Gardner and you make that sharp right
into those garages
she's like garage number four is where
guns and roses lived mm-hmm some weird
[ __ ] that they had in that you know and
then she just started pointing out
places and faster pussycat this oh yeah
that name yeah who hung out there in
fact that's right across from the sunset
grill and when looking Don Henley wrote
the song along with the Eagles and I
don't know ya know what would such an
interesting [ __ ] neighborhood that I
wish somebody then I ten-hour
documentary on and showed from like what
was happening in 77 mm-hmm - I can't
imagine you know I'm Jersey
I'm a fat [ __ ] Jersey snorting coke
and Motley Crue had taken over the
airwaves oh well I can't imagine
what they were doing here yeah do it in
like 82 83 when they were playing like
the whiskey and [ __ ] Starwood and
gazzarri's and [ __ ] like that I mean it
was just it was all those bands it
became huge word local guys that were
just in that Hollywood la scene just all
up and down Sunset Boulevard and [ __ ]
like that so it was crazy back then man
and I caught the tail into that you know
I wish I would have been there when I
was like you know in like 80 81 when
they were you know doing that circuit
I caught like 83 84 is when I started to
go down to the Sunset Strip when I was
like you know 13 14 years old and [ __ ]
but I mean I did I got to see a lot of
those [ __ ] bands it ended up being
[ __ ] rock stars you know [ __ ]
Motley Guns'n'Roses dude I remember
being in like junior high maybe early
high school and talking my friends and
it's like ah who's playing this weekend
it'd be like Guns N'Roses at the [ __ ]
troubadour again like you know it was
almost like whatever we already saw him
like you know what else is happening
like that's how [ __ ] crazy with and
you look back on it now and you're like
holy [ __ ] like we were seeing these
[ __ ] like you know guys turn into
legends back then at first I was ya know
was uh yeah maybe four don't wasn't oh
yeah mm-hmm
wasn't no they wonder who was big then
like motley motley was Molly uh-huh
Molly's first record was already a
faster pussycat warranty from they were
a little after that they were there were
local guys in that to ride Hera but yeah
I stood see fast supposed to get a the
country club and the Troubadour and the
whiskey and all that [ __ ] yeah at some
point like poison I saw all of those LA
bands man like I remember being it as a
[ __ ] signing like for poison because
the some girl that I was dating at the
time was big into them and and I went
with her to the signing and it was like
80 I don't know I did 83 84 something
like that and it was when they just
gotten signed so I got to see all those
all those cats you know it was crazy man
I mean to think back now and it's so
different now a lot of those clubs
aren't even there like the coconut
teaser which the club that runs to play
it at least the play all the time I was
odd
you retinol right up Crescent Heights
and Sun Heights is right on the corner
right when you made that one Laurel
Canyon get right on the right I did copy
that yeah really is he sure you had to
go there like a Tuesday night yeah Terry
I admitted to they [ __ ] did that that
was that was one of the clubs that I got
like signed out of like the the first my
first behind they got a record deal like
we were playing like the teaser and [ __ ]
like that and it was now this is like
when the the the new metal thing started
happening and we would play with like
bands like System of a Down cold chamber
static acts all those new metal bands
and we got signed at the tail end of
that corn we were like the last I think
I always joke we were like the last
[ __ ] band to get signed from that
scene this is rampage no this is now
been called society one society one yeah
this is now like in the late 90s there's
like 97 98 how long did you work with
them for but six years
then you bumped into how I we had a the
same booking agent so my band my old
band society one had the same booking
agent his ministry and we had a mutual
friend this guy Paul Raven who was a
bass player and been called Killing Joke
so he knew al and he's the one those two
guys kind of introduced me to Al like in
2003 or something like that and they
were like you know if you need a guitar
player call sin and I remember meeting
out and he's like yeah I'm gonna call
you I need a guitar player and like two
years later he [ __ ] calls me and he's
like I need a guitar player for his
other band called the revolting [ __ ]
and this is like 2005 now and so I came
in to the revolting [ __ ] is just a
guitar player and we were it was the
revolting [ __ ] in ministry going on
tour in 2006 you guys roll yeah and and
I was doing double duty because he was
singing for revco for Elton Cox and
ministry and during that tour is when Al
and I became like close and we start
talking about music and all kinds of
[ __ ] and he was like man because I want
you to help me you know right the next
ministry record and so ministry went to
Europe after that you
best run when they got back he flew me
to help Paso Texas which is where he was
living at the time and I went out there
with my little [ __ ] tascam four-track
recorder with some riffs and and he was
like you know let me hear what you got
and so I played him you know one of my
riffs and and he's like I you know it
sounds killer he's like let me know when
it's done and he splits so I'm in the
[ __ ] studio with this engineer that I
just met and I just [ __ ] finish this
tune and called him when it was ready
and and that's how that record happened
this record called the last sucker and I
ended up writing like half of that
record with him and I was honestly just
like hoping one of my riffs would end up
on a [ __ ] ministry record that's all
I was like really hoping for and ended
up doing like half that album with him
and that was 2006 and been here ever
since and I can't [ __ ] get rid of me
yeah this is a band that spans what
three decades yeah no that is just so
are you one of the newer members I'm
considered one of the newer members even
though I've been with him since 2006
right but I've been with him me and and
the keyboardist JB John Bechdel have
been with him the longest so yeah like
we've had wood it's sort of turned into
like a spinal tap with drummers and you
know we've had a bunch of drummers and
and we've had different bass players and
[ __ ] like that but um but JB and I have
been with him now since 2006 you know as
you see when you came in saw the old
circus yeah [ __ ] yeah that somebody gave
you we were talking about how I in the
70s and 80s you didn't have the internet
so you had to buy circus and there was
another one hit rate or hit Parader cuz
I didn't I'm not a big Rolling Stone guy
rolling I mean there's more for me the
whole food type people yeah I've always
liked music
I've always loved me it's like I love
the A's B's and C's of it
the promotion that the smoke the glitter
I like who shouldn't have glitter like
me I'm one of those guys but the thing
that's always intrigued me the most has
been the writing process the writing
process on music is something that I can
never even fathom have a hard time
writing a stupid [ __ ] joke never mind
but see over the years from the
documentaries that have been out and
stuff like that you learned how things
get put together you go away for six
months and come back ribs
uh-huh and you send them to the drummer
who writes the lyrics now then he sends
them back to you yeah and it's this
process but then you go into the studio
and something else gets added in there
by coincidence and it's just like comedy
there's no way yeah it's taken two or
three variables figuring them out for
what they are putting them together and
then at the end they all come out the
same flavor kind of yeah music is always
like I said that would have I would have
gotten the musician rap but I was such a
[ __ ] hell on wheels I would have sold
my guitar eight times and when the cops
are looking for you stuff having it
tough to have a guitar you have to be on
the run tougher get away with the Gojira
man look out with a guitar that's it
he's got a good thought yeah no I hear
you though and I and I you know that's
one of the things that interests me the
most is not not only the the live the
performance part of it which I love like
that's just one of the ultimate highs
for me is is the performance but I get I
get the same rush from creating music
and from knowing okay I'm gonna write a
song or we need to do an album or
something right and it's like you know
at the beginning of that day you have
nothing written there's nothing in front
of you right and by the end of that day
you know that you're gonna have like a
blueprint of something and it's
something that I do I wish like there
was like a formula or there was
something that I could say to people do
this this this and this and you're gonna
write a song I don't know what that is
Lord
oh noes I don't know you got the jeepers
app book yet did you get the man I did
yeah I'm looks as you look through it I
haven't yet no I don't when you first
look through it's going to look like
Chinese really you might as well get a
Chinese book and call me up and Jill go
Joey go [ __ ] yourself and hang up
because it's drills it's it's a lot of
chili chatty
you know when you look to write you read
as much as you can about writing mm-hmm
and then one day you come to the
conclusion that you could just read so
much it's just [ __ ] time to write
mm-hmm just write just shut the [ __ ] up
and write just did that that's what
you're doing I want you to give me a
schedule for the week and from 8:00 to
10:00 you gotta write then from 10:00 to
12:00 you'll be jumping jacks mmm
they're from 12:00 to 4:00 one you're
gonna [ __ ] the wife then from 1 to 5
you're gonna write again you know I'm
saying that yeah like I finally realized
that the 15 years that you have to put
writing whether it's music comedy it's
always in blocks you get my musicians
yeah there's something else you guys
studio times expensive you ain't got
time to [ __ ] around now once you get in
there it's all girls in you Alex
and there was record labels paying for
this and at the end it comes out your ID
no I saw I was actually in two hours
wondering because with comedy they like
comedians will try out bits and they
they evolve over time it is am I wrong
or do songs are they just out when
they're out I did you don't really get
to like workshop them at all
no I mean we don't let's act an
interesting point we really don't get to
sort of you know use a crowd as guinea
pigs because I mean in the sense that we
write a song and then it goes on a
record
or we perform it and at that point we
just we kind of see if people are
digging it or not but by that point in
time the song has already done its
article written it's already recorded
it's already whatever so we kind of just
get just gets put out there and you know
so yeah we don't really get to sometimes
you know depending on how much [ __ ]
they're throwing at us we can tell if
they dig it or not you know so really
you read about these or you know all
these people who like Black Sabbath's
recorded volume four and eight hours who
do you know one day yeah [ __ ] like that
that's it
[ __ ] Christ that's so kind I know they
had it written before they were there
you know but it's interesting what we
said because but I do know one thing I'm
not a musician and I knew I do know when
I write ten jokes all right I know
there's two of them in there don't leave
me get me somewhere okay the one that
I'm banking on to get me somewhere that
one duds three times but the one that
was okay really gets a good laugh and I
got something go where no I always knew
it I just didn't really focus a lot I
focus out on that one cuz I was I think
in the studio after you've laid your a
tracks down you know sailing you play it
you know if there's magic or you know if
there's no match that's what it's always
a big sharpie
there's too many musicians who are
[ __ ] perfectionist there's such
perfectionist that they couldn't even
keep their band together they annoying
everybody staying now you know yeah the
guy on pink flow I helped there's so
many guys that perfectionist you would
even a little regular pool directed you
label tell you whether you want to hear
they just want to get their investment
exactly they just want to recoup their
investment so I'll tell you whatever the
[ __ ] you wanna eat you know it's that 19
year old assistant that sees you and
sperm comes out of his mouth like this
and says that lay this guy used to has
[ __ ] brilliant well but on top of all
that you guys know in the studio yeah
it's something that has to it's very
true very true I see it in all the
documentaries in the 50 years I've been
listening to music that's something I've
always thought about so you do it or or
you like during Ozzy's tour the first
one mm-hmm they were playing flying high
again they played like two songs from
the harm that was already written right
and recorded basically they would do
that sometimes that happens of course
when you're on tour and you might put on
two songs you have to see we got people
always get pissed off by the white horse
yeah by the third song you're rocking
the roll
and also this guy wants to do a
tearjerker go [ __ ] yourself alright cuz
you thought about your mom at the toilet
I don't give a [ __ ]
keep going and then at the end on your
time go inside and serenade those
[ __ ] big bows that one here that I'll
be over the door zing
well the question I have then is because
I think you're probably right then I
think it would be different for a
comedian like Joey versus someone who
just started but like for your early
bands did you know what was magic
or did you ever have an album that
you're like this is gonna kill and then
it would didn't go as well ya know I
mean it's very true in the sense that
you can usually tell what has that magic
and what you think is gonna do well and
go over well you're not always a hundred
percent right with that sometimes we
think you know [ __ ] this is the one like
this [ __ ] tune is gonna go over great
and it's the one that you're kind of
like at it's just kind of a throwaway
it's there it's cool but so that it does
surprise you sometimes but for the most
part you know when we're in there we're
always kind of just looking each other
the only have this [ __ ] has this -
well this is the one something yeah yeah
it is something that it's it's it's
really hard to describe it but it's this
kind of it's this electricity you feel
with it this magic you feel with with
you know when you've recorded it and
you're listening back to it that you
know it's gonna [ __ ] do something
like that's why I've always hated radio
the army has hated radio radio is for
people who have one-hit wonders mhm
radio should be for people who sang one
song and that's what things s but that
was it no because why would you play
living after midnight til I'm [ __ ]
lengthy and you never play you don't
have to be old to be wise right exactly
that's so yeah what's there's so many
other tracks that are they lookin
amazing
it drives me [ __ ] crazy radio because
of that reason and it's like I like the
whole secret of banach for years Sinha
was a picture show
about Saturday mornings what we did is
children you know it doesn't you mean
those children we had a [ __ ] stupid
paper route or you carried rocks for
your father never you [ __ ] did for
three or four bucks a week
and we decided on them and we'd walk
from Atwater Village down somewhere
mm-hmm and we went you morning hours
couldn't wait to come back and listen to
it and we listened to it front and back
three times before we went out and laid
our opinion and it was just great
because and everything that you bought
had expected to listen to you found the
gym again found something that you fell
in love with even more now for the song
that you originally bought it for
exactly well I bought sabotage for
example you like sabotage worse I bought
it for a hole in the sky yeah and I like
the album cover how it looked
thrill of it all our first song on the
other side has turned out to be mom
all-time favorite sound in the house on
the wall time yeah tight to Sabbath
bloody Sabbath but it's so weird I like
that yeah I'm always like listening to
aloud and whatever I'll my bots are
strong for there's something else in the
second side that's gonna [ __ ] your world
up we didn't tell you about it we wanted
you to buy the out let the radio keep
pumping this party tonight [ __ ]
exactly and on the other side of the
last run you got the Greeks don't wanna
freak success it's true though man I
mean that with every record that I own
that's the case you hear something okay
well this here's the single or here's
what they're there they're promoting and
pushing but there's always one or two
tracks like the deep cuts that you're
just like [ __ ] man this is cool as [ __ ]
and that stuff will never get played on
the radio you'll never hear it like you
don't I mean being promoted and [ __ ]
like that so I miss that kind of [ __ ]
from back in the day like getting the
record and it's exactly I was for me
dude it was like [ __ ] going to music
plus and Glendale on my didn't do it
says I know so you get a different
musician every Saturday now 12 episodes
the favorite record store Nick and there
why the Mississippi yeah go buy a vinyl
and let's put it on and describe the
whole process of involve your mother
wasn't home your mother was at your
aunt's house playing cottage so if it
was a double album or the album open
yeah fine you could roll the joint man
clean the seeds out I mean it was such a
[ __ ] process you guys have like a
like a ritual every week it was a ritual
yeah it was a ritual
it was a ritual pretty much if you had a
day job and you made whatever for 450 an
hour every Saturday you bought it out
mm-hmm and you stopped the Burger King
got the chicken sandwich and mm-hmm you
stopped at the Kung Fu store and then
took the stars it was just part of it
let me tell you something else I don't
give a [ __ ] how many times sin I picked
I could pick up sin and sin would say to
me listen I'm gonna go up there by Neil
Young and Crazy Horse live today
why because I heard it I like it okay on
the way home guess what's it will have
Judas Priest sin after sin because when
you went there something about the album
covers yeah grab you save us it was a
[ __ ] beautiful process that this
country has released all right I like
iTunes too I like the idea said calling
me and saying listen to this Jam and me
going on my phone and the rest of three
buttons but that's not what it's all
about I still went on board you know I
go to atomic mmhmm yeah it's not only me
but yeah but it's cool as [ __ ] because
it makes you work yeah you have to look
through whether you're going through the
album's this is reminding me of going to
a video store like that was my thing
when I was a kid that's innovation is I
just went to in an Austin and I'm did
anyone ever have like a rental place for
albums that would have been awesome for
kids to go and don't know it's [ __ ]
savages will rip the album did you
realize I used to go through the [ __ ]
trash bin at music plus in Glendale just
to get the [ __ ] cut out the album cut
outs that they would throw away
like that's how hardcore I was into
wreck
and albums and just staring at them and
you remember reading every [ __ ] thing
on those things dude you know I look at
these albums that I have behind me and
sometimes I buy the album just to show
the show people how lucky we were what
we got to read you know I mean some of
them still have the original sleeves now
and some of them don't but now the
sleeve was your thing for the day like
this is now that I never forgot this was
I think one of the most brilliant hounds
of the packaging I'm gonna [ __ ] isn't it
boom boom okay Led Zeppelin in through
the out door final loud came in the
[ __ ] bag I know Pearl Jam did that to
Joey
yeah but twenty-nine thousand [ __ ]
years later okay
you bought the album okay in through the
out door came in a bag okay this is a
special edition one no big [ __ ] deal
but it shows a guy at a bar tremendous
picture there's the same thing about Led
Zeppelin all for the imagination huh say
anything about Led Zeppelin they're all
for the imagination say anything in my
Led Zeppelin and say anything let's let
me Lynette all for the imagination
they put as much time into the album
cover as they did the music sometimes
but here's where it got beautiful it got
beautiful well somebody took it out of
here it got beautiful because the
original sleeves to this album cover was
a sleeve that was projected to be his
last night mm-hmm
John Bonham's last night do you remember
and if you took a a wet sponge huh and
you sponge around however Olga Hollis
came up yeah who does that
know who designed these was that the
band did they have an art designer the
the label who have these whoever was the
[ __ ] genius of those days
yeah I buy a CD of ministry now I open
it up it's a page the songs they thank
the dog and that's it
Nicole I guess I mean how many like did
they I would love to know like the
percentage of like let's say 10 15 years
ago you used to print 50,000 CDs now is
it 10th Alec oh yeah yeah I would love
to see how many like because you
probably would put that may see these
anymore
dude it's I mean a band like like
ministry which was like a
platinum-selling act in the day you know
in the 90s now it's like we're lucky if
we sell [ __ ] 50,000 50,000 downloads
yeah just because we don't sell records
anymore dude people still are [ __ ] like
I mean the even before the records out
people already have our [ __ ] everywhere
oh it's you know it's a it's a slippery
slope there it's usually goes to the
people men that are manufacturing this
that are all thieves and they steal the
[ __ ] and they just start and a lot of it
starts happening in Russia is where
we've seen a lot of it start like that's
where most of the bootlegs start from
and it just starts to spread from there
and do we need sell [ __ ] [ __ ] anymore
dude
I mean back in the day this is a band
that would sell a million [ __ ] you
know albums now it's like [ __ ] not
even nowhere near that a big song Jesus
Jesus built my hot rod just one fix yeah
I mean that album some 69 huge that was
during the whole Lollapalooza 90 where
are they - where yeah you guys don't
like the [ __ ] you will a blueprint
for like Rob Zombie showing at that I
felt like Rob Zombie Nine Inch Nails Oh
getting man send all that [ __ ] look at
this
nah dude I know I know they put effort
into there it was all part of the whole
experience of getting a record man it
was all of this stuff yeah a [ __ ]
poster winner is when you did the acid
you forgot it was in there later is that
the original poster no probably oh my
god
these are reissues okay I thought it was
just the fact that they give you all
these things
it gave you something it gave you
something but collected you a little bit
war with what the [ __ ] you would do it
now
united the van Halen buy in 1981 those
out without 84 and they would thank the
Hilton's like all you guys would thank
the hotel chain so I knew when you came
to town that's what you were [ __ ]
tonight except it was the [ __ ]
craziest thing they would thank the
health and pictures of the tour covers
were interesting I don't know what I
shot the longest shot
they sent me a DVD 20 of them to give
away the friends is [ __ ] you opened it
up and it was a page there was a guy
there every day with 22 [ __ ] cameras
texting what they do with those [ __ ] to
the pictures what they do with those
[ __ ] pictures now nothing nothing
put him on the thing show off to people
give the people a little something extra
get interesting them again like an
experience how it used to be dude that
was I was like I mean you know when I
was a kid and and I would like the the
record that got me into playing rock was
kiss alive was the first Chris live
record it was I was six years old my
older cousin who was like 11 at the time
brought it over and you know I I was
into music because my parents always had
it playing in the house and and but I'd
never heard anything like that so this
is 75 did and so he brings it over and
he shows it to me and I'm like I
remember asking him if they were
superheroes because I was looking at the
[ __ ] cover and he goes out of [ __ ]
rock band check it out and so he drops a
needle on the record first song deuce
comes on and dude and I'm looking now
it's a double live album with the
booklet with the other live Paul oh [ __ ]
yeah and literally man my life just
completely turned upside down at that
moment and I was like [ __ ] dude like I
still get chills I said like you do that
dude and and I remember telling my
cousin I was like what's that who's that
he's like oh that's a that's a lead
guitar player and I was like that's what
I'm gonna do man at six years old I told
him that because of that whole
experience of
that record hearing the music looking at
those [ __ ] visuals just reading
everything I was completely just [ __ ]
just engulfed in that I would come home
but I had that out and I hung out with
this family that they're a great family
and the youngest kid was my friend and
he had the album and I would listen to
it at my house first while I was eating
I got half the school Santa and then I
go play and then we go back to his house
and we put on in the attic and we do the
agate of course yeah the whole [ __ ]
thing you know and it was full had told
that he brought four years and he
brought would talk to me about the kiss
and I would kind of shut him off and he
didn't understand why what happened was
just kidding me we had kiss alive and
the one half of that I want you you rock
and roll over rock and roll over was
that the water yes right I remember we
brought those two together like yeah
actually we didn't hang out yeah you
know it was in those days you had to
hide the album I'm going home because
you didn't want your alright Robby's or
your friends so it was funny I listened
I loved rock and roll over but I really
liked kiss alive and that was it you put
kiss alive on and you would scroll
through the pictures now man just
[ __ ] great pictures how I have really
on the guitar like I can't even describe
the word cool like you can't even know
what you look cool no no he looked like
a [ __ ] guitar player yeah
but to make up in our house standing and
it didn't make me fall in love with the
guitar I mean it fell in love with kiss
but you know what happened though that
kid died the car accident
I took kiss alive and I took rock and
roll over and I put in this casket I
don't want and I promised I'd never be
into kissing a tomorrow 30 Wow [ __ ]
years to listen to music no and I hope
that P forgives me and having
but that that's the deal while man just
loved kisser oh yeah yeah but they took
my whole kiss [ __ ] hair from man I
know everybody buried him with kiss out
my hubby kiss probably had three hours
at that time 78 for yeah they'd had
three before the live record
Lorelai real live and then rot yet so
that's why I was different to kiss but I
still remember those pictures of how
dark the other man the photography was
amazing amazing amazing I'm I just
wanted to jump on your skinning all that
guy yes so [ __ ] bad-ass yeah dude
yeah I mean you see in [ __ ] picture
this Simmons with blood
all by gods in the fire looks like Lee
yeah he looked like Lee with the bong
before Lee was doing a Simmons
impersonation here why I am Jewish you
all right Lee take a paper towel
spitting it again real quickly just to
give me peace of mind not to go find you
nothing okay
just filter no no no no dog I was okay
too because that's how it started it
started with a paraquat okay okay you
sure uh uh uh I think I'm gonna have to
go to the doctor just to check it out
anyway so I think I'm okay no I know
your business if I know anything about
you
tomorrow you'll be at the doctor at 8:01
a.m. if I know anything about him you
never said you had the contract like I
got you know I'm sayin the chick touches
his shoulder he goes for this disease
you know but she she was a hot bag I got
my skin Lee it doesn't you can never be
too safe you can never be too safe fungi
toenails yeah and that's like that's why
the the horse main thing is crazy cuz
I'm crazy about you I'm not saying I eat
the best food but I'm crazy but like
just watch chicken I don't do any like
that the eggs like [ __ ] I don't do no
officer ray the restaurant knock it off
you know what an off the Ray the
restaurant is anything that your
girlfriend wants to go eat that's an off
the radar excellent anyway the gene
Simmons no no no just a whole the whole
album thing
I miss it now and that's why I - when I
got the record player for Christmas you
know my home is Olema who's got the time
yeah now who's got the time to go to all
me but forgets it's four hours from
school Joey okay because you find 20
things you want then you find ten things
that you really want and now you're
walking around with 30 pounds of albums
decide which 10 you're gonna put back
and you still drop the 800 alpha every
time I go to all be by drop 303 honey
so you're like magicians past 300
everytime I go no amoeba and you're
gonna stand on line and you gotta get
tortured just okay so if you were single
you'd get lucky take a couple doubles
and spend your entire day there cuz that
like I've been there and I see the
professionals come in and they zip
through the you have to have time to go
to me by gotta you know how many times
I'm good on me but with no glasses on
I'm happy like I forgot my glasses thank
God I'll get the assistant asking if
he's got it the assistant and the river
don't you get the [ __ ] out of here
because of that dog I sit there with the
[ __ ] things I used to live three
blocks long beaver and I found [ __ ] I
don't me but I did that's a process
there man it's a process
yeah but hey it was the type of [ __ ] I
found yeah I went looking at eBay and
the cheapest this is after the kids
mother has stepped on the album you know
they lit the cover on fire two songs
were missing they want the hundred bucks
for the out oh I went to home Bieber and
I got the DVD for the small $9.99 well I
wanted the vinyl yeah you're not gonna
find the vinyl I'll Westen's [ __ ] ten
thousand yeah yeah so you know [ __ ] like
that yeah that's what I'm talking about
okay you wanted the vinyl Joey you're a
trader no I wanted to hear the [ __ ]
music that's what I wanted to hear and I
still have my parents vinyl from the 60s
like I have my that my dad's old animals
records and stones like original yeah
you by Saint Mary's yeah yeah it was a
different gauge yeah before I think like
maybe 78 I would say gauge on an album
was different let me face I'm either put
in the Sun
all day oh yeah I [ __ ] that it
melt yeah awesome when they leave it out
with the car for what day you got a
frisbee yeah you gotta [ __ ] the little
frisbee and [ __ ] oh man those old
records are like they're sick of this
[ __ ] tape nick is a [ __ ] that's how
you know know that's how I know because
the gauge yeah feel baby it does to me
maybe I don't know talk to maybe not
it's true
feels like a super thick on the on the
old ones man and it's a lot lighter on
the newer ones do you ever think about
like what would happen if you had kept
all those records Joey like leave the
money they'd be worth or no I gave them
to somebody I gave to somebody who I'm
still in contact with Jesus and part of
me always wants to say you don't listen
to that [ __ ] but the other part of me
says how can I do something like that
yeah do something like that she's going
through some heavy right now and Herod I
weren't dating
we never dated we were just music
friends yeah i shoplift in all those
arms anyway i used to go to half mars
pure profit if there was 200 albums in
there I clipped a hundred oh oh my god
yah a hundred I legitimately sweat for
because you know it was we got you guys
didn't see everybody got [ __ ] in the
ass because I got [ __ ] in the ass
between we had all things they were
pushing all three things on the still
the 8-track the cassette and the [ __ ]
out at the same time at the same time
the 8-track was getting absolved but the
cassette was still coming on strong with
the album so you need to buy a cassette
for your car but that wasn't the same as
having mm-hmm
the experience now that's the [ __ ]
experience that's why right now I really
don't give a [ __ ] Netflix feels me a
special anymore I really don't because
I'm gonna put on the experience on now
I'd rather put it on vinyl rather give
me the inside pictures lyrics the whole
bit man a [ __ ] tattoo there was a
band who gave me at that through kiss
did that take kiss the dad say that
Cheech and Chong gave me a rolling paper
you know everybody took Carrie in those
days when huh yeah I missed that yeah I
don't mind and and you know how much
albums were Lee at that time 6.99 we're
a [ __ ] hour I paid signal if you
bought it out like let's say you would
Sam Goody Glendale Museum what was the
one on Sunset Strip at our power yeah
you paid this $5.99 was tax but if you
went to like a place that was down the
block from you some hippie ran an
evening he just had a ticket smoke dope
and sell reckons he charges 750 give the
sense what do I give a [ __ ]
he's trying to make a Liberty he'd even
play the AL before you know yeah I had
one of those they put it on absolutely
yeah yeah could you damage like as it
would see these you can scratch them
tapes the the tape can come out how do
you ruin other than heat can you ruin an
album the belts so that's the only way
can go like you're not gonna it let's
say if you put in somewhere Ben's like
something like what I'm doing right
there that's not good okay as your ad
will Bend Oh
people will come over here we're
professionals ago I got him the milk
crate excuse and straight yeah you know
let's no no there's people who are
[ __ ] e rickity tickity about their I
don't blame that's how it be waked e
dickyvicky covers see if I knew what I
knew now I would I would have saved
everything I would have had Millions
I had albums that theory you know blah
sad to play a saboteur original releases
I had all that [ __ ] original release
with the lyrics the muck and the devil
innuendos yeah yeah hold on one second
let me do some shout outs I got more
[ __ ] questions for you too little
wearin don't go nowhere
mr. Willis I love you Randall not a
Mogan Josh Hass three-side Thomasin Matt
Manchester Nicholas Taylor cavea Gould
and Kevin Glenn cafe I love you
[ __ ] all right don't forget this
Thursday Friday Saturday
this Charlotte that Charlotte comedy
zone yeah I think about it for a minute
villas in it's been a couple of rough
days that I'm getting flashbacks of
Vietnamese never that anyway the comedy
zone Charlotte North Carolina I'm ready
to rock Rogen's in town and a different
Club
luckily you have seized their Saturday
night it's gonna be a Rock'em Sock'em of
a [ __ ] weekend at the UFC this
weekend all right Charlotte so I'll see
you guys at the show Thursday night
tip-top Magoo eight o'clock you're out
of there by 10:30 you're stoned to the
gills you'll get a burger then you go
home you ready for working on Friday and
the third week of February I'm at the
Comedy Works in Denver Denver is coming
out to watch comedy so I'm letting you
know now [ __ ] this is gonna go quick
so do what you need to do but don't
forget I don't give a [ __ ] about none
right now all I give a [ __ ] about
Thursday night at the Charlotte comedy
zone all right be there or be [ __ ]
square
you know this podcast is about second
chances and just people were [ __ ]
made did something that watch the
journey you know you got these people
who hit you up on Twitter and Facebook
and they want to do this and they want
to do that they want to do this and I
understand what you want to do but you
go on Twitter Facebook ain't the answer
you gotta go do it you know you're a guy
that grew up here in town
went down that Sunset Strip you know got
it for this band from there I got into
another band from there you [ __ ] the
drummer's girlfriend so you gotta go to
another band from there you know I'm
saying what the life in transition well
it's really beautiful now you know I
like to sit all these professional
musicians like yourself down and start
from day one like I was nothing how was
it Abed we lip synched we synced our
Michael Jackson but here's the problem I
was good the drummer was good and the
guitar player was good the bassist had
the electrical equipment and he was
terrible but he was the bassist so one
day we had a fire and take everything
for now we went we had we were a good
trio but we had no sound here
that's a problem I've been there man
so I love that journey and this is a
journey that's from what kid who
listened to ministry yeah from somebody
who listened to ministries you're a
painter watch him I did yeah yeah this
is from absolutely you know today I shot
a scene with that lady Michelle Lee oh I
don't watch them Michelle Lee Oh since
Thomas I you know who doesn't leave
nothing is it melissa melissa leo
you know this yeah yeah you know you see
these people for the one of years now
and one day they you are standing next
to you in a room talking about this and
this and that yeah has nothing to do
with what you're doing you like if well
nobody would believe me
yeah don't be what this lady's as nice
as she is and she just said [ __ ] you to
one of the [ __ ] peoples oh it's uh
it's still you know it still trips me
out and it and it still happens to me
too I'll be in the studio sometimes
without and we'll be sitting like this
and he'll just look at me and he'll be
like well you know what do you think we
should do here and I'm like and it
[ __ ] like hits me and I'm like did
you really asking me like you know my
appendix still it because I'm still like
a fan and it still takes me back to like
when I first saw the band
and to me it's like it still doesn't
seem real at times I'll be on stage will
be on stage and [ __ ] Europe man
Poland I remember this one particular
time there was 500,000 people in the
crowd right and I'm up on stage without
and I when we're playing like just one
fix one of the ministry classics yeah
yeah and I'm up there and I remember
just looking over my left shoulder and
he's up at the mic and he just kind of
looked over at me and just kind of
winked and I deferred like a few seconds
it's like I wasn't there and I was
watching like myself it was like kind of
this weird out-of-body [ __ ] that went
down and I was like what the [ __ ] is
this really like me like am I really
[ __ ] doing this and then it just kind
of felt like I just landed back in my
body again cuz it was just so weird to
be up there with like one of my heroes
doing it like like I'm in the [ __ ]
band like it's it's still weird to this
day sometimes it's it's like I don't
really believe it I'm doing it obviously
but it still [ __ ] trippy man it would
freak me out more if I didn't know what
you were talking about yeah you know you
know it's like then but think about a
guy like me that at one time I was this
cell next to a guy and you know I was
the sound next to a guy watching stupid
movies you know and then on Sundays I'd
watch football and stupid movies and and
one day I'm standing next to Michael
Irvin doing the best damn sports ed you
know talking to him but nothing wanting
to tell him the next thing you know I'm
on stage in Vegas with Tim Allen for a
whole [ __ ] weekend talking to Ellen
and finally the last day I got the
talent hey man you were the final push
when I found out you got locked up and
made me really want to go out because at
you know and then yeah I tell people to
wait for the miracle to happen mm-hmm
it's such a [ __ ] like how long were
you out there [ __ ] kicking doors down
dude from the time I was 18 so I mean I
slugged it out for about 12 15 years in
the Hollywood scene dude just being all
just here
just hear it session musicians should
let that everything everything did
everything and it was like did I mean
there was no school for this it was just
the love of music that carried me how'd
you pay your bills dude I did everything
from [ __ ] repoing cars to [ __ ]
working in mail rooms to [ __ ]
telemarketing to [ __ ] whatever the
[ __ ] I had to do to just pay my bills
and continue to do music like I I didn't
you know I didn't I'm gonna graduate
high school but I didn't go to college
like my parents split when I was about
13 the idea was I was gonna study music
and I was gonna go to like Cal arts and
[ __ ] get a degree in music and show
like that that didn't happen my parents
split I had to work I had to help my mom
cuz it's I'm an only child so it was
just me and my mom so I had to like help
her and and I knew that College just
wasn't in the you know it just was gonna
have for me yeah so I was like I need to
work I want to do music but I need to
help my mom so I always did whatever the
[ __ ] I had to do man job wise I didn't
give a [ __ ] and and you know I had to
keep this dream alive of doing music and
I always knew and it may sound weird to
say but I always knew something was
gonna happen I didn't know when but I
always felt it and I don't know if it's
just like you know just how much [ __ ]
love and passion had for music that sort
of enabled me to know everything yeah
did you know everybody's telling you I
you're not gonna do [ __ ] are you gonna
just [ __ ] you know you should just
give up dude I heard that my entire life
was you know you should just stop you're
never gonna be in you know if we're
gonna make in a band you're never gonna
do this never gonna do that all the
doors [ __ ] slamming in your face did
but it just it was [ __ ] blinders me
dude and I didn't listen to any of that
[ __ ] and I just kept [ __ ] going kept
going and it you know I mean [ __ ] meetin
people and doing things and [ __ ]
perseverance dude was key
and you know I mean I've been lucky and
blessed to have the [ __ ] career that
that you know that I've had I feel like
the luckiest guy in the [ __ ] wall to
do this I always want to do like I don't
know what the percentages for comedians
but I always wanted to do a percentage
rate for bands no dude it's it's it's
horrific you do got a better chance to
let hit the [ __ ] lottery ten times
yeah then getting a bandwidth for people
to go all the way to the top what's the
top for me is making great [ __ ] music
and sustaining yeah you know that's a
great band for me and sustaining and
sometimes guess what one of the three
gets a little crazy yeah this is the
suit listen deceased look too much glue
on a toy and the band breaks up but
there's always two of the three guys
yeah still going yeah awesome band then
they aren't something different that's I
love it I love all the whole aspect of
[ __ ] music now from beginning to end
the thing I couldn't imagine what is the
band I have a hard time being me I'm
saying I have a hard time something goes
damn I have a [ __ ] plane I can't
imagine doing that with six people yeah
it's very true man I mean having being
in a relationship okay is you know what
that's like
now imagine adding another five guys to
that just the band and everybody trying
to have the end result would be the same
and everybody having the same goal
it did everybody's going like this man
in different [ __ ] directions so it's
a tough thing to keep that together
that's why you know this guy leaves that
guy leaves but it's it's a tough thing
man and then to live because you're
basically living with these people on
top of all of that on top of the music
thing it's you're living together when
you're on tour you're traveling you're
with them all the [ __ ]
time did so it's not an easy thing it's
not like when you're a kid you think
about I want to be in a band it'll be
great oh yeah you'll see that's all
that's all you think about you know what
I mean but once you get in it and you
start to see the reality of all the [ __ ]
it's it's tough man I don't want to be
on the tour bus by myself never mind
with four people should they want that
my feet exactly the laces in the middle
of night I can't I can't even you know I
did prison I did the half an hour you
know I'm a camp I always knew I wasn't
cut out for [ __ ] Cheryl the bed are
you saying that the tour bus is worse
than prison ah that's my boy here every
week it can be I could get done okay
getting off a [ __ ] listen to me first
off you get off stage you just did a
great show and then you get in the
[ __ ] bus all right that dries all
[ __ ] night you're in the back you
might have a few beers
you might knowing you little thing pull
the curtains if you think I could fall
asleep with some guys rattling you're
[ __ ] crazy
maybe you'd love it maybe like all right
oh yeah there's nobody and that was when
there was no texting I can't imagine
texting now I'm trying to go to sleep at
night with a half a bag of this fabulous
little [ __ ] meal in the middle of
night and I go flying off the cliff like
the fugitive what's that movie with
[ __ ] Harrison Ford and for yeah it
[ __ ] you I don't ever want to be in a
bath huh you want to take me from here
in and down the corner let's go
giddyup but that bust [ __ ] at night
that's brutal
yeah hop every couple days for a hotel
room yep and for a good night's sleep
not that down maybe when I was 21 and I
was doing blow and you gave me [ __ ]
Cosby pills
I wouldn't think I have a mess driver
all day do you ever get scared on planes
though like it was just I get scared on
everything we like the guy 20 stars
before I go on a plane did I not give
you a [ __ ] edible
before one on the plane we had 5:30 in
the morning not during the morning both
ways that's like the [ __ ] I could pay
you for I'm all today he wasn't worth it
get the [ __ ] Jesus yep
I've been lucky in that I've never been
freaked out by flying chili no I forgot
my flying but that being said I've had I
had one flight we did going from [ __ ]
where we going from Australia to like
South Africa or some [ __ ] dude I was I
for the first time in my life I was like
this is it like this is it
I was like I was asleep and I was in the
last [ __ ] row of this plane and what
woke me up was my head banging against
the [ __ ] side dude and dude you know
it's a big-ass plane dude and it just
starts [ __ ] going all over the
[ __ ] place dude
and I'm like okay you know it's
turbulence whatever but this doesn't did
not feel like any turbulence I'd ever
felt before I honestly thought we were
just doomed and women started crying
throwing up dude people like right next
to me throwing up and the seats in front
of them like it was [ __ ] brutal
didn't it lasted I mean it felt like a
couple minutes which a couple minutes of
that heavy turbulence feels like [ __ ]
forever dude and we finally leveled out
people were going to the bathroom like
women I couldn't walk they were so
freaked out and scared [ __ ] like that
and and I was like when we finally
landed in Johannesburg
it was [ __ ] like kissing the ground
did I was like [ __ ] I don't know want to
get on another plane again and the next
day we had to get on another flight from
[ __ ] Johannesburg to like [ __ ] Sao
Paulo Brazil or some [ __ ] in another
[ __ ] like ten hour flight
it's [ __ ] brutal that's like the
[ __ ] crazy if I can yeah doesn't [ __ ]
what but I can't be an old plant unless
you're playing six hours on them like
New York and then to London or someone I
just don't have the patience and anymore
for the flying did I you have to be
prepared the [ __ ] iPad video movie
the whole bit book share drugs well I've
only done it encode twice and it was not
that fun to be honest who there's no
line that's what you've been to Israel
it was like 13 hours I think something
like that well maybe not 13 years like
well eight hours people start stinking
to me and they serve homeless but like I
asked you guys do you guys get to fly
first class like that has to be radical
for 12 hours it's cool it's cool but
it's still not 12 hours not that cool
that's cool enough for that yeah dude
this planes not in a room yeah those
plans that are just phenomenal that that
JetBlue [ __ ] miss from New York to
Boston or New York to [ __ ] JFK
that's a beautiful situation if that's
what you do if you you're telling me
that you just getting off a [ __ ] show
and you're up all night you get on mint
blue at 6:00 they don't wake you up till
11:30 that's five hours of sleep I know
that's not a bad little [ __ ] the
answer to that now which is the secret
and I can't sleep on upon it
me neither that's the secret I can't
either if you could sleep on a plane
that's no longer drunk without three
whiskey's and xanax leapin or just like
passing out passed the [ __ ] out does it
really whatever yeah the little guy next
to you touches you dick while you sleep
you can [ __ ] chargeable international
[ __ ] dick tightening up in the end I
don't know the Tauri a deterring aspect
of your life and Rudy's anybody else's
walked into the studio has been
those year tours on its long ass along
with a two-week break this is between
that yeah is it
those are brutal dude that's crazy yeah
that that second week you're like I
don't wanna go now you really start
contemplating quitting the band how much
what do you having a bank when you're
out to you you do how long can you live
you're like I gotta go do this [ __ ]
again with these lunatics yeah so you
only we get to spend the night in a
hotel most nights
no no depending on the dust or exactly
or there was a [ __ ] plane tour yeah
sometimes it's a combination of both
like say you say we're doing this us run
for like six weeks or something right
there will be times where we might have
to [ __ ] do a gig go to the hotel for
a couple of hours our hotel lobby call
is like 2 or 3 a.m. to take us to the
airport to fly completely across the
country to do a gig that night to get
back on a plane to go back to where we
just came from and it just depends on
the routing of the tour so there's [ __ ]
where we're on a bus but we have to
break it up with flights in between and
show like that and you're not sleeping I
mean you're [ __ ] you know you just
did a [ __ ] gig and then you're you go
back to your hotel just to grab your
[ __ ] basically yeah and then to go to
the airport and go through all that
[ __ ] the security and all that [ __ ]
and then you're flying and I can't sleep
on a [ __ ] flight so I'm like awake
for like four or five hours and then get
up do soundcheck do interviews do
meet-and-greet do the gig and then do it
again that night and then go [ __ ] fly
back again and you know yeah I mean no
idea don't know they really don't know
they really don't know the work that
happens when you get there and they
don't appreciate the work that happens
before you get them more the last year
more than ever
you know you get Facebook's and the into
it is and people tell you their stories
and people real interesting
but once every 10 days you have this guy
that thinks that this is a [ __ ] duck
walk mm-hmm I love those people well
dude that's on vacation I love it with
people that they don't understand that
there's a commitment of this that they
think that somebody picks up a phone and
makes a call and that's a they think
that I've never ran into this as much as
the last six step a year six months to a
year that this is just a given away a
lot of the work that if they say if if
you can look into a crystal ball and see
the work and the sleeping on couches
delivering with no money that you could
you're gonna go through and the next 10
years on average for you to do this most
people wouldn't do this what makes you
over pack now when you get into
something like send it do you know what
you got yourself in there so it's the
passion of it I love these people that
just think that they just gonna stroll
up here with that girl looks and Gayle
Mathers and [ __ ] do what the [ __ ] it
took years [ __ ] yeah it takes years to
get good at something and then it takes
another year a couple years to learn how
to navigate in that world huh and that
takes two more years to learn how to put
the navigation and the talent together
it's such a [ __ ] journey you know
when you came in and you said that I've
never even thought about it from that
perspective young very true you were a
fan of theirs and then you're in this
[ __ ] band now looking over looking at
out jorgensen going how the [ __ ] did I
get here mm-hmm
I got was just a relic in that water
village chasing lizards I think this
sounds until the remains resting yes I
mean I'm in a very similar position I I
was I drove cross-country and I found
podcasts well and I've always been a
huge fan of stand-up comedy and not so
much in the podcast anymore cuz we've
done tons of
Podcast yeah but when I could when I get
to go to Joey shows it's great like just
even like being like backstage or or uh
like the fact that anyone knows who I am
you know blows my like it still freaks
me out kind of well yeah it's very it's
very flattering but I'm always like I am
whenever Joey of the show he oh he takes
pictures at the end I try I stand close
but I never I've never expected I was
gonna jump in right right it's a it's a
very it's a it's a never anything that I
would have cuz you planned it it would
seem it sound like you're not exactly
what this band where you planned you're
sure I would have never guessed this is
where word of my life tanya has Wow it's
it's interesting hearing you talk it's
you know I'm very jealous that you you
had such a conviction and you knew I did
you know I mean that's the one thing I
gotta say I don't know if I was just
completely stupid or what but III did
have that conviction and that knowing
that this was it for me and I think a
lot of it had to do with my dad it was
it's in my blood my dad used to be my
dad was a singer in Mexico in the 60s
and he had a band and I still have his
45 which they're released which was like
a number one hit single and like the mid
60's and [ __ ] like that but he was a
singer and I think that's where I got it
from and he he never pushed me into it
and it was never anything that he was
like you know hey I want you to do that
if anything it was almost like the
opposite like he almost didn't want me
to do it but I think I was born with it
like I think it was just something that
I had in me because you know I would
hear music from zeroes I can remember up
until I heard that kiss alive record and
that solidified that I was gonna go in
this hardrock kind of you know genre but
I think that it was something I was born
with and it's something that even if it
all ended today right now I'd still be
doing it like I would still be on a
[ __ ] some corner or something [ __ ]
blame the guitar and some [ __ ] bar
whatever just still doing it like it's
it's it's not anything I'm that that you
can just shut off at least for me you
know
whether I'm up here or down here it's
it's still here so it's always gonna be
there for me you know and that's what's
that's what's I think pushed me so far
in my eyes like I've you know I've made
it kind of how you said earlier you know
what's making it well for me it's
creating writing music [ __ ] touring
being you know sharing what I do with
other people and [ __ ] like that to me
that's making it like it on my terms
I made it everything else that's
happened the [ __ ] Grammy nominations
the [ __ ] this and that like dude
that's icing on the cake that [ __ ] that
you never think about you know what I
mean like I never did [ __ ] I'm a kid
from East LA dude never in a million
years what I [ __ ] think oh you're
gonna be it you know you're gonna be
hanging out with Tony Bennett the
[ __ ] Grammys you know target shooting
the [ __ ] with him and and you know it
did it just [ __ ] that you never think it
would look at people who knows
[ __ ] the lowest released la
tamales from the garbage can will he
still talk to me did you oh do you
always say that so there's always with
all the time come up to me like we was
saying a lot about their families yeah I
know bring their moms no making your mom
do what I thought I robbed a little
cancer kid named box one time from a car
mouse door would they still be hugging
the ayah no I do I do think that fellow
these victims of the art that you dare
to get the music and pain to talk about
on snare whatever [ __ ] that day whatever
drives us to do listen when I got into
this I didn't get it it's miss to be on
TV
send not at all yep I didn't get in us
to be in the movie those are little
options so I was running out of options
and I like the lifestyle yeah and I
understood what they were doing make
people laugh I do ever free yeah yeah I
know the corners every guy actually
think I get the front eight balls
because I come to your house tie any
money you'd say no nice you know I get
you laughing next email ago right
all right I can't give you a label but I
give you a name that half and I got you
at left it's the same thing yeah
I didn't know well laughs - felt like
the people and a lot of times I have to
remember the laughs and I really
appreciate it like now yeah
the first 10 or 12 years economy I
forgot what laughter was so when people
would talk to me about it and understand
what they were saying mm-hmm
I was going through a divorce I lost a
[ __ ] child through a divorce I didn't
get involved but now I genuinely like to
laugh and it reminds myself what I do to
people yeah and that is better than the
money better than anything like I don't
give a [ __ ] about it I never did I don't
want them to say these I want to [ __ ]
Subaru hatchback right whether I got ten
thousand two thousand dollars I got a
Subaru hatchback bro yeah that's just
the way this is gonna give me the most
value for my dollar I work hard for my
daughter
plain and simple you follow me but
that's that's what this was for me and
I've been realizing lately though I mean
if for 25 years that the [ __ ] charity
mmm-hmm the journey has been so [ __ ]
mind-boggling like the only regret I had
is that I didn't put a computer chip in
my brain the camera to establish all the
thoughts and all the different things
cuz there's so much you forgetting yeah
maybe cuz you want to tuck away but sure
yeah now that's the the journey I think
is one of the most beautiful things man
that a lot of people don't know don't
appreciate and don't get and will never
get and it's what got you to where
you're at right now man the twists and
turns and the you thinking okay well I'm
gonna try this or I'm gonna try that and
it not going the way you thought but
then this other thing happened and that
I always find interesting when I talk to
people and and like when I love watching
documentaries on [ __ ] where they really
talk about that kind of [ __ ]
and what you know the the different
avenues that they had to take to get to
where they're at
I always find interesting you know what
I mean it's that jutsu me too I love all
that [ __ ] yeah because you know it's
like the more you fail at little things
just for trying them the highest success
rate gets in a way I don't know how to
explain that Snell's dumb but that's how
it's always felt like to me like I look
back at all the things I did like I'm
trying to outline a chapter from 95 to
like 2040 a day just [ __ ] around and
it was a no festival hmm I was at the no
festival
I really was [ __ ] milk everything was
no who would tolerate that yeah and then
I got mad tv I got like a movie I got
bass ketball
uh-huh in 98 and it was like every time
I was about to really [ __ ] on myself
I would get assigned oh not a big sign a
little Sun you know like two days on a
movie really and you got a wife come on
Wow come on oh yeah as an extra stop
pulling my leg huh it is the line you
know and it's like these little things
that keep you alive there are six months
even though you're eating tuna even
though your friend liked it 40 bucks you
just know it you just know something you
know yeah that's the [ __ ] best
feeling in the world
I'm Wallace absolutely I wouldn't had
nowhere to go if I [ __ ] up here in LA
that's it I would believe that little
world here you go do County with ya New
York and bang it out there and then Joe
when you can eventually have to be here
for something now and then let me go
that's the guy that robbed the Comedy
Store today and I gotta say the first
time I saw you was it flappers in
Burbank okay yeah yeah yeah go with
[ __ ] with Philippe years ago yeah
years ago that that was my introduction
to you and I was there and my
even I don't know if it was in New
Year's yes it was it was something with
who he is and it's [ __ ] sitting there
man
front row and you [ __ ] came on I
didn't know who you were and I did I was
[ __ ] completely floored I was just
like who the [ __ ] this is
this guy is [ __ ] amazing I was nuts
and my wife was pregnant she was about
to have the kid and I had been home for
10 days straight I was about to stab
somebody
Felipe called me to say come down and do
ten minutes dog as I'm staying all night
dude
and I mean I just got to say you [ __ ]
killed you blew me away
I blew me away and I mean from that
point on I've just been [ __ ] sanded
like huge fan did so I mean my hat do
you do thank you amazing did I go on
it's like I'm just a conservative club
so I go up there extra heavy-footed
the first 30 seconds too long you throw
ball oh they have no idea they're
talking about Disneyland the next day
like oh I love it you know it's it it's
a psychological of it yeah yeah if I
took ministry and put them in a place
where the where the Beach Boys play
right like Hendrix helped money for the
monkey yeah if I type of [ __ ] you know
saying like it's like that like you got
to go out there and let them go it is
what this room's about exactly solo
projects yeah I am I mean I do a lot of
session work to this day and I also do
like from time to time I'll do like my
own side things like right now I got
this this old-school power metal project
called three-headed snake that I'm
recording an EP for right now and that
is all three songs reso old-school
[ __ ] like I did like you know
old-school priests kind of sounding [ __ ]
you know what I mean
and it's just for fun like it's just
I happen to have some time and I've been
written these songs a few years ago and
and I have this amazing singer and so
we're tracking that right now actually
and we should have that done probably in
February by next month so I always do
[ __ ] to keep me busy and you know I'm
always doing like I said sessions and
other artists and bands always hit me up
- you know we do such as you and all the
Capitol Records sure like ever anywhere
man yeah anywhere there's a studio that
wants me and they pay oh yeah you know
we put just play the [ __ ] guitar go
both vocal yeah yeah I'll do both I'll
do like some bands they're like hey man
can you write something for this you
know and they'll give me like an AI
basic idea they have and I'll write the
guitar parts if they want to solo I'll
do that blah blah other times it's just
hear the parts but we want you to play
these parts and stuffs already written
and then I just you know basically add
my [ __ ] to it but it's already written
so it's both I get both yeah interesting
dude bro yeah man no and that was an
education before of the couch we should
have [ __ ] a tape that but it was the
same thing I get high with Lee we forget
[ __ ] they just heard them you should
have heard Joey on earlier when I was
talking to him when you realize that
I've been clean and sober my whole life
oh you know what I was just gonna say
cuz you look great I uh I thought you
dropped the phone on we don't no no no
as a musician you you're around
everything you know yeah and I could see
somebody going I've never done this but
I do drink and smoke pot it's not at the
time you said you're completely then not
have a drink I've never had a sip of
beer never smoked anything never done
one um no beef don't definitely no yeah
no I totally PA
and respect and I'm the same way man
honestly then God honest truth is I've
never been curious about that stuff I
never got curious about that stuff
that's like if I had to say one thing
that's the thing the second thing which
is gonna sound very uncool and very
unlock and roll is I remember early on
my mom having a conversation with me and
her telling me you know because she
could see that this is what I was where
I was headed and I remember her saying
you know you're always gonna have my
support and always gonna back you
whatever you want to do and you want to
do this just don't get involved in like
drugs and alcohol and stuff like that
that was it wasn't like a big heavy you
know set you aside and we're gonna have
this tight was nothing like that that's
the only other thing I could sort of
think that I always carried with me and
other than that I mean there really is
no other big reason I've been around it
dude you I mean no man I've do do I go
on the road my pockets are full of [ __ ]
that people give me and and and and yeah
I just I've never been curious about it
man just never anything I was ever like
not a sip of beer but I have no idea not
ears is overrated yeah a lot of people
gonna get man it's like I did it didn't
I what does it call to a taste you have
to like you have to grow to like it's an
acquired taste in it but and you know
also knowing I have a very addictive
personality so I kind of I know that if
I if I did something I liked it I would
like the [ __ ] out of it and I would
probably more those guys what the [ __ ]
knows they have addictive first value 14
what are you addicted you let me get a
tissue in there if you don't mind oh
just you know like let's just say I I
know I like but like dude you know what
14 yeah I did man you like it I I did
you know I I just knew that that
ever I liked there was no middle ground
for me it was just like you know I
either hated it or I [ __ ] love the
[ __ ] out of it and I just and I just had
a feeling all right well I'm not really
curious about this stuff but if I ever
if I did do it and I did like it I would
probably be the guy that just went
completely off the deep end
with it and I did sense that early on
yeah you know I like soda knows it I
love this [ __ ] I saw it again offered me
a water how offended what no soda right
I'll take juice third who yeah I'll ask
but you know for me water euros I that's
the order yeah yeah I got no soda like a
nice juice let's do some juice right
we have no juice but we got kool-aid the
cherrywood what by that I never thought
about it like that at that age yeah I
was I was very shy with marijuana used
for my first year yeah I did not want it
to get out I was very I'm especially
around my martial art friends I did not
want them to know I did any type of
mouth yeah yeah for me to break loose
from that I had a stop hanging out with
them to shun them my bar lately and look
what got me if I would stay my little
[ __ ] karate I would have been a marine
right now replying done some with my
life but no I chose back I was a dirty
kid alone that's given light and fly is
the would do [ __ ] like that so dude I
still remember the first time I saw a
bong I was jamming at a buddy's house
when I was like 12 or 13 up in the
Burbank hills and we're sitting around
in this guy's garage and they were all
like 3 or 4 years older than I was and
we were just [ __ ] playing like priest
covers or whatever the [ __ ] we were
playing and and all of a sudden the
drummer it was the it was his house it
stops and he said I wouldn't take a
break and we all just kind of sat down
and I remember them breaking up this
[ __ ] bong that like lit up like had a
light and she liked that and I remember
just
sitting there and I was going what the
[ __ ] is that like I didn't even know
what the [ __ ] it was did and [ __ ]
like they're like passing the [ __ ]
around and I was like what the [ __ ] and
I just I remember got to me and I just
like pass it to the next guy but like I
remember that shitty night not knowing
what the [ __ ] what was the first time
you saw cocaine or heroin how old was I
yeah probably 18 shoot snorting okay
yeah I just shooting probably early 20s
and it traumatizes yeah dude his
Christ's brutal did yeah I saw that [ __ ]
as like a child like running up a flight
of stairs to call for a friend and you
get the third floor there be a guy with
his head down now with the needle of his
arm is all you know and you gotta walk
past this guy [ __ ] horrendous no then
it was like an epidemic in New York
thanks one of my aunt's house so right
oh and he had told the story about him
Comedy Central
there was always a guy shoot in the
hallway I mean he was like a flower like
you know when you walk into a building
as a plant on the hell I was there he
was always there with the rubber around
his arm and he would have pushing it in
and I would look at him for like a split
second cuz that [ __ ] makes me faint and
I just run up the stairs it was [ __ ]
horrible horrible horrible now I can't
imagine being a young kid and not like I
was around that as a kid I knew what a
chitchat yeah but to see it for somebody
to whip it out and funny you wouldn't
tell him in there what the [ __ ] you
don't [ __ ] brutal them I mean I've
seen [ __ ] did every [ __ ] thing you
can imagine I mean been around a bit in
rooms guys that I used to play with and
you know everywhere I did it was always
around me always
III think I know maybe like two or three
guys in the music scene that have never
touched anything like at all other than
that everyone has and I mean that's cool
and I know I'm not like really not like
anybody yeah yeah
yeah listen who wasn't for heroin we
will have no Alison changed exactly yeah
thank God for H you know they gave us a
full house I was in change dirt is
brilliant don't ask the piece the one
before that jars was it was then if some
jars yeah yeah masterpieces and these
guys were [ __ ] drooling all over I
just I know I'm losing teeth man [ __ ]
are you [ __ ] crazy Lee losing Pete
why does he'll make you lose teeth I
don't know maybe you forget to brush
your teeth I have no [ __ ] idea but
I'm just saying it just happens what the
tooth girls are tickets to [ __ ]
change your perspective is [ __ ] oh my
god was like the other musicians
response to it to this like like honey
I'd like how much grief did you get
early on um you know not as much as as
you would think that's pretty cool
actually yeah it was it was weird I
don't know if it was just because I was
I it was just they saw the conviction
right me and it was never an issue I
never really got like any [ __ ] for it
like people just early on be like oh you
don't do this or whatever like it was
just that was it it was never like you
know I never got any any real [ __ ]
for it enemies and with with ministry I
mean I'll you know no secret he was did
everything man I mean he was you know on
heroin and I mean he hit the rock bottom
before he cleaned up and yeah I mean we
talked about that [ __ ] so he's one of
those dudes Jorgenson that nobody talks
about but he's been there back now that
I'm back alright yeah
you know that guy that sit him down it
would take you 10 years to pick his
[ __ ] brain what he knows he had hits
he knows what it is to [ __ ] and and he
at the very top and if you're involving
teleph he knows what to be at the very
bottom and you
he's never stopped mm-hmm and you have
to look at that go while that count for
something my [ __ ] bull absolutely
know about your book I was a clown for
some in my book [ __ ] yeah you know all
these bands though that are coming back
to play whatever it is whatever they
coming back just the fact that they're
coming back now they given the
opportunity you know won't even one you
know Dan what are you doing you're 66
you're 64 you look as good as you do
you could still move around the stage or
at least for two hours you're right
exactly yeah contain the tongue out yeah
you know you can't do it every night
there do it four nights a week but you
can still pop out to it oh yeah yeah the
opportunity to ask these six yeah you're
going you go back on the bread diet you
dye your hair again a young girlfriend
you give it a deuce a week to get the
old scum out of your son that sack to
get that nutsack work I'm like it used
to when you afford that's all you need
you go to [ __ ] CVS you get some loo
genex nice to money a week what's that
it only cost you hundred a week to have
the girl know you find yourself a Harvey
Weinstein leftover somebody who's on the
[ __ ] list and they wanted to do whatever
they need to do to make this small 300
and they come over for days and polish
your knob your 69 your practice they'll
tell you what to hide they don't send
you 708 you know saying I did that sack
you don't want to put your nuts
it might die yeah by the time you set me
before your nuts in the woman's mouth
did they just die that's like that's I
eat little fruits and [ __ ] Jamaican
[ __ ] die it what's your website buddy
sin Kieran calm and the website we'll
kind of find that he's got everything
toward page yeah oh yeah everything tour
dates everything that we're doing very
interesting [ __ ]
Thank You Man from the heart I
interesting I appreciate that
I like this whole East LA thing that how
you guys what's your relationship with
war guys of course Jesus I would have
died many times dude now these
[ __ ] used to walk around here
like they were just yeah they were like
a gang dude they were like there were
just dudes walking around in the scene
and I you know the last time I got to
say the last time I saw them Eric Burdon
came up and and did spill the wine with
them and I was like holy [ __ ] dude
that's like one of my all-time favorite
songs I was battle line there the world
and we got Eric yet let's close with
illa wine spill though that is a [ __ ]
gin that's the jam did and a half yeah
listen brother you have an open door you
thank you money time you're coming I
know you're right go on it yeah man drop
it talk shift for an hour
sounds good the Man of Steel it's been a
real pleasure I'm pissed that I don't
know you early how bad do you go how far
back to go a Rudy well Rudy I met for
the first time just a couple years ago
but I mean you know known of him for you
know from [ __ ] him back in the day man
I've been falling at cat since early 80s
so but we met for the first time we did
we did the Randy Rhoads remember jam up
at the Canyon Club and a guy did suicide
solution with [ __ ] Rudy dude on bass
and I was you know the deaf that's a
highlight for me did you know to do that
[ __ ] flick and playing Randy stuff with
Rudy up on stage it was [ __ ] crazy we
had uh Stephen Perkins I think from
Jane's Addiction played drums on that so
it's [ __ ] blast man no I won't get
into the [ __ ] rent then see Road
School down the cold in here that's
amazing I'll do absolutely you know
that's just I heard his mom had a guitar
schools Burr loris yeah Burbank yeah
yeah it was actually North Burbank North
Hollywood right in the border but she
lived and ER Randy was from Burbank went
to John McGee high which singeing I went
and I remember ice to go to the mile the
junior high library and look up the old
yearbooks to see pictures of Randy in
there while I was like going to that
same school and shed so that was a big
Randy Randy Rhoads film you know I was a
big Sabbath fan
Ozzy left God loser was outdoors that
happen when I was in the village and I
saw the EP the first 84 songs and I was
done now I was yeah I'm getting egged le
van Halen step top absolutely it's like
he just stepped on there yeah what's the
whole difference it was a whole
different [ __ ] job
yeah we're getting for that next time
Vishal man Oh blah said any time you
want to come any well meant you know my
number here hold on one second let me
just do through things here and we'll
get out of here in a decent way number
one it's a new year and your chance is
it [ __ ] two weeks
you got Valentine's Day you want to look
good with your significant other this
Valentine's Day right then check out me
on these matching pairs are you kidding
me or what I know for a fact Lee's gonna
have his matching pair so him and Mama
could look at each other and giggle and
do all that fun stuff because it's a
unique it's a fun gift for you and for
your Valentine then the perfect balance
and comfortable fit and exciting prints
don't spend another Valentine's Day
giving that same old gift I'm gonna take
it some wing store and give her a stat
no check out me on this calm and find
the best match for your match me on
these are the most comfortable fun on
these you and your significant other
will ever hold then made from the
softest materials on earth we're talking
three times softer than cotton that type
of stuff this Valentine's Day get your
partner a gift that's both for both ears
order by February 5th at 10 a.m. for
free standard shipping so your gift
arrives on time you want to have it
right then which you gets home you throw
some petals on the floor no rows which
eat people we put like poison ivy right
you put some poison ivy on the
or you put a candle you put me on these
on and you already got your me on these
on who's more who's more romantic than
you nobody that's why you gotta go to me
on these right now beside all that fun
they got a hundred percent satisfaction
guarantee
me and these guarantee that your and
your significant other will love your
matching pairs or your money is back
genus is back
so what Uncle Joe is gonna do for you is
this so you hit a homerun on Valentine's
Day me and this has an exclusive
Valentine's Day for my family here for
any first-time purchases when you
purchase me on these matching pairs
we're gonna give you 20% off 20% off and
free shipping free shipping free
shipping who's better
then Uncle Joe Joey nobody go to me on
these calm right now
you're gonna love them they offer 100%
money % 100% satisfaction guarantee and
if you don't love your first pair you
get your money back alright it's a
no-brainer get 20% of matching on these
for you and that beautiful significant
other yours right and 100% money-back
guarantee what are you waiting for what
are you waiting for
you're sitting there looking at me order
by February 5th for free standard
shipping go to me on these calm and
quote Joey me on these calm / Joey and
get 20% off your matching pair and free
shipping and the guarantee that's me on
these Dom / Joey down you gonna put the
winning of them putting are they gonna
go home and put the underwear on and
surprise enough
first off you don't either when you take
a shower but let's say you are an animal
she likes the odors of your neck your
armpit but you want to suck the pipe
without having a bad look on the face
and you want to lick your balls freely
you know you open your legs like that
like a savage and they stung that
[ __ ] muffler debt if you want that
you gotta go - hello - she calm right
now it's a portable bidet clean jazz
whole [ __ ] tremendously you
understand me it takes ten minutes to
install you don't need a [ __ ] plumber
even in any like me can do it if I could
do it you can [ __ ] do it you got it
you install it and after that your
bathroom becomes your [ __ ]
kingdom you know what it's like to get
your balls licked with a little hot
water sprinkling yeah [ __ ] do you
know that have you ever fantasized about
that no you haven't see that's the type
of [ __ ] uncle Joey brings to the table
on a [ __ ] Wednesday all right
slinging dick and giving out bubblegum
plus you got a ninety nine ninety day
guarantee and it comes in an array of
colors go - hello - she calm right now
why should your [ __ ] stink like a
billy goat when you have hello - she no
more [ __ ] using toilet paper and
killing [ __ ] trees in the Amazon keep
your [ __ ] clean with [ __ ] pride
you follow me
hello - she even has little towels that
you take and you wipe your [ __ ] clean
with him tip top Magoo and she's licking
that little muffle
I'm Valentine's Day you don't know what
the [ __ ] you're gonna say thank God for
uncle Joey and hello - she calm right
now let's cut this [ __ ] listen I would
love to walk around with a dirty ass
hold on there hey wiping my ass I love
just right from the sides and putting
underwear on but let me tell you
something you never know when the victim
wants to lick your ass out of debt and
that's why you gotta have hello Toshi
calm as a portable bidet
hello - she's calm right now impressing
church man and get 10% off [ __ ] end
the story you're walking you'll leave
the house with [ __ ] confidence you
understand me women use summer's eve
agile scrub [ __ ] that [ __ ]
you got [ __ ] hello Toshi sprinkling
your [ __ ]
anyway I want to thank hello douchey I
want to thank me undies
I want to thank since we're in Killeen
getting from the beautiful band ministry
drop some knowledge on us and I want to
thank all you [ __ ] and get
ready Charlotte sharpen your helmet
uncle Joey's coming to town I don't want
no [ __ ] [ __ ] when I get there
Stars everything meshuggener pills are
doing everything so show up early get
your tickets and stop [ __ ] around
we're throwing some [ __ ] heat this
weekend you understand me stay black
let's get that spilled of wine hit that
girl one more time for [ __ ] sing I
love you [ __ ] have a great weekend
I love you [ __ ]